♪ ♪
>> Tucker: HERE'S A STORY
THAT'S RECEIVED ALMOST NO MEDIA
ATTENTION.
IT'S BEEN LESS THAN A YEAR AND A
HALF SINCE DONALD TRUMP GOT
ELECTED COME UP THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY HAS CHANGED PRETTY
DRAMATICALLY.
SIX YEARS AGO FOR EXAMPLE SINCE
THE 2012 STATE OF THE UNION,
PRESIDENT OBAMA SAID THIS ABOUT
IMMIGRATION.
WATCH.
>> I BELIEVE AS STRONGLY AS EVER
THAT WE SHOULD TAKE ON ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
THAT'S WHY MY ADMINISTER AGENT
HAS PUT MORE BOOTS ON THE BORDER
THAN EVER BEFORE.
THAT'S WHY IF THERE ARE FEWER
ILLEGAL CROSSINGS TO WHEN I TOOK
OFFICE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S UNIMAGINABLE
TODAY, OBAMA COULD NOT AND WOULD
NOT SAY THAT.
INSTEAD, DEMOCRATS ARE CALLING
FOR THE ABOLITION OF FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT.
ISIS WAS DESCRIBED AS A STRIKE
FORCE --
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
THREATENING LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS WITH ARRESTS IF THEY
COOPERATE WITH I.C.E.
IMPOVERISHED DEMOCRATIC CITIES
LIKE BALTIMORE SET ASIDE TAX
DOLLARS TO HELP ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS FIGHT DEPORTATION.
HOW LONG BEFORE THE NATIONAL
PARTY CALLS FOR GIVING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
YESTERDAY ON THIS SHOW, WE
INTERVIEWED AN IMMIGRATION
ACTIVIST WHO SAID FOREIGN
NATIONALS OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO
VOTE ANYWHERE IN THE COUNTRY.
IT USED TO BE A FRENCH POSITION.
IT'S NOT ANYMORE.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS MODE
FOR ADVOCATING GUN-CONTROL AND
PUSH FOR GUN CONFISCATION.
HERE WAS HILLARY CLINTON'S
POSITION ON FIREARMS TWO YEARS
AGO.
>> I'M NOT LOOKING TO REPEAL THE
SECOND AMENDMENT, I'M NOT
LOOKING TO TAKE PEOPLE'S GUNS
AWAY, BUT I AM LOOKING FOR MORE
SUPPORT FOR THE REASONABLE
EFFORTS THAT NEED TO BE
UNDERTAKEN TO KEEP GUNS OUT OF
THE WRONG HANDS.
>> Tucker: THOSE WORDS COULD
HAVE BEEN UTTERED ANY TIME IN
THE LAST 30 YEARS, BUT THAT WAS
THEN.
DEMOCRATS HAVE JUST SPENT THE
LAST MONTH OPENLY CALLING FOR
GUN CONFISCATION.
YESTERDAY, FORMER SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE JOHN PAUL STEVENS
DEVOTED THE REPEAL OF THE SECOND
AMENDMENT, OTHERS HAVE FOLLOWED.
THAT WOULD BE UNTHINKABLE A FEW
YEARS AGO.
IN THE 1990s, YOU OFTEN HEARD
BILL AND HILLARY CLINTON SAY
ABORTION OUGHT TO BE SAFE,
LEGAL, AND REAR.
AS RECENTLY AS 2009,
BARACK OBAMA AGREED.
WATCH.
>> LETS US WORK TOGETHER TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF WOMEN
SEEKING ABORTIONS.
LET'S REDUCE UNINTENDED
PREGNANCIES.
LET'S MAKE ADOPTIONS MORE
AVAILABLE.
LET'S PROVIDE CARE AND SUPPORT
FOR WOMEN WHO DO CARRY THEIR
CHILDREN TO TERM.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS THE
POSITION OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
FROM ROE V. WADE UNTIL ABOUT
YESTERDAY.
EVEN THOUGH ABORTION SHOULD
REMAIN LEGAL, IT WAS
UNDESIRABLE, IT WAS SOMETHING TO
BE AVOIDED IF POSSIBLE.
THAT'S ALL MOST VOTERS FEEL.
DEMOCRATS NO LONGER SAY THAT.
THE PARTY'S BASE IS FOR
ABORTION.
THEY WANT WOMEN TO --
PLANNED PARENTHOOD IN COLORADO
DEMANDED A NEW DISNEY PRINCESS
WHO HAS HAD AN ABORTION TO BE A
ROLE MODEL FOR GIRLS.
THIS IS OUTSIDE THE MAINSTREAM.
ARE THEY THE TOPICS, ARE THEY
THE ISSUES THAT DEMOCRATS ARE
GOING TO RUN ON DURING THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS QUESTION ARE
JOINING US TONIGHT IS SOMEONE
WHO HAS SPENT A LONG TIME IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, JENNIFER
PULMONARY.
SHE SPENT YEARS OF THE HEART OF
IT.
SHE'S GOT A BRAND-NEW BOOK OUT
AND SHE'S DOING VERY WELL ON
AMAZON, IT'S CALLED DEAR MADAM
PRESIDENT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE.
A LOT HAS BEEN WRITTEN ABOUT THE
CHANGES IN THEIR PARTY.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS CHANGED
AS MUCH IF NOT MORE AND IT'S
GOTTEN VERY LITTLE ATTENTION.
DO YOU ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
PRESIDENT OBAMA GOING OUT AND
SAYING I'M GOING TO CRACKDOWN ON
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION, COULDN'T
SAY THAT TODAY?
>> NO BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENED IS
THE PROBLEM GOT A LOT WORSE IN
CONGRESS DIDN'T DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT.
PRESIDENT OBAMA GAVE THAT SPEECH
MANY YEARS AGO, THAT WAS WHEN WE
WERE TRYING TO PASS
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION REFORM